but often you know oranges and lots of
things that we can feed people with in
here justin grant is no stranger to this
downtown vancouver back alley the former
grocery store manager knows all too well
about the food being discarded perfectly
fine missing a tip grant says during his
four years with the davie street your
independent grocer he'd sometimes donate
items to the homeless in exchange for
help a way to de-escalate situations in
the store i don't know if you've ever
seen a 14 year old kid who lives on the
street saying i don't want to shoplift
in your store can i have a sandwich
that is absolutely heartbreaking so i
would say if you go and sweep the
outside of the store the sandwich is
yours his unique management style had
been going on for years with no
complaints then in october the parent
company loblaws accused him of stealing
600 dollars worth of product and without
warning he was fired in four years i
have never taken anything from that
company it was part of the culture that
i was trying to build down there was
caring grant has now filed a civil claim
against loblaws for the firing in other
occasions with the store's knowledge he
donated some dog food to the local spca
and provided a cake to one of the
homeless persons on their birthday his
lawyer believes he was wrongfully
dismissed the most unfair aspect of this
is the fact that he had no reason at any
point to believe that what he was doing
was not ok it really was someone who was
trying to do
good
and
had a promising career ruined vancouver
police tell us they were contacted in
october and did conduct an investigation
into the theft allegations though in the
end no charges were recommended i don't
want my name associated with any kind of
theft and i just think that is truly
unfair it's sad more than anything else
none of the claims have been proven in
court loblaws has not responded to our
request for comment krista dao global
news